there was a CNN reporter and a lot of
reporters out there that were tweeting
out or putting on social media that
picture the image of children behind in
cages immigrant children and blaming
President Trump for that it turns out
those pictures were taken when President
Obama was in office so some of these
reporters were taking down the pictures
there's the picture right there
and we asked Kelly and Conway about it
earlier this is what she had to say this
is actually the CNN fight she had on the
same thing because they're accusing the
president of separating families of the
porter that's a policy was already in
place and they're looking and reporter
retweet that jet that false fake tweet
about the migrant children being in
cages your CNN colleague retweeted that
to migrant children I suppose laying in
a cage to make the point against this
president happened under President
Obama's watch and then deleted this way
because it didn't fit the narrative you
saw this exchange all night oh yeah
birdies forwarding this tweet there's
there's a former member of the Obama
administration who'd actually put out
the tweet as well then had to delete the
tweet after realizing that it was his
administration that had done it it is so
obvious that this has been a problem
going all the way back to the Obama
administration he's not wrong when when
the president suggests that it's not as
though he has a choice about separating
parent from children if he actually
wants to arrest illegal immigrants at
the border there is no choice because
the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals has
ruled that he has to separate children
from their parents he can't keep the
kids with their parents in detention
that's the problem if the Democrats
wanted to solve on this if they want a
solution on this they could get one
tomorrow they don't want a solution on
this because they do want these pictures
they want more of these pictures they
want more kids who are in a problematic
situation like this so they can blame
President Trump and then claim that it's
his cruelty that's the cause of all good
for her though for calling out that
reporter and saying what are you doing
over there if you're gonna lie I want
you to explain why you're doing this and
the reporter didn't have any answer well
I'm not sure CNN has any answers about
its bias with regard to president no
they've been exposed